je vais vous annoncer quel est le
smartphone de l'année 2022 après avoir
testé des dizaines de smartphone dans
tous les sens haut de gamme pas haut de
gamme pliable pas pliable bref des
smartphones de dingue il y en a un que
j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé mais
vraiment adoré pourquoi parce qu'il est
très doux au niveau de la photo on a
l'impression d'avoir un côté un peu
réflexe de la vraie photo graphie c'est
pas forcément la marque à laquelle vous
allez vous attendre il ne s'agit pas
d'Apple il s'agit pas de Samsung il
s'agit pas non plus Xiaomi il s'agit de
oppo oppo c'est une marque qui grandit
énormément en France bref c'est la
marque a sorti mon smartphone coup de
cœur en 2022 c'est le find Dick 5 Pro
partenariats photos avec un seul Blade
la puce Marie siliconics bref un
smartphone que j'adore qui est pour moi
le smartphone de l'année en 2022 et vous
d'ailleurs quel est votre Smartphone
préféré de 2022 dites-le-moi dans les
commentaires